you also wore the kobe armband today  what went into your thinking to wear  that in this game in particular  um  you know obviously that was my my idol  that was my you know inspiration i was  my favorite player  uh  you know the shoes i wore i've been  wearing the last couple games you know  were you know dedicated to him  um  and you know i just today  before i took my nap um  you know uh i do it sometimes i watch i  was watching you know some film  you know and and some moments from him  in his career  uh  you know this biggest game of my career  thus far and you know  you know i went the way that armband to  honor him and  you know kind of share that moment in a  way